What's the dichotomy in having an ego?
When is it good and when does he get to a point where you have to check your
ego?
Okay,
so
the dichotomy is pretty clear.
Um,
ego drives you absolutely.
It makes you want to win.
It makes you want to perform well.
It makes you proud of your achievements made you want to be number one.
And those are all good things.
And I fully,
fully have those myself.
I mean,
my ego will keep me up at night trying to win at some ridiculously meaningless
thing in the world,
especially when I was younger.
It was kind of stupid.
Um,
but the ego can also get you in trouble,
get you in trouble really,
really quickly.
For instance,
I mean,
you can,
your ego can make you sabotage your coworker that's all on the same team as you
so that you can outshine him,
right?
That's ego.
You can vote down a plan,
a better plan,
because that plan isn't yours.
That's your ego.
You can
chase some material items,
some things,
something that you don't really need.
Maybe in some cases it might even be something that you don't actually even
want.
And it's just fueling your ego,
which is,
which is a really bizarre thing to see.
It can make you step on your subordinates,
right?
It can make you undercut your peers cause that eagle flares up.
It can make you,
your ego can make you dig in,
dig in on some stupid ideas that you've had.
Those are the kinds of things that ego too and all those things are negative.
So
that's pretty clear to me where ego starts going sideways and,
and I would say even though like my ego always fueled me to,
to,
to want to win,
but I never was that out of control where I was like screws and screwing people
over because I wanted to win.
Now I wouldn't do that.
That wasn't part of my personality wasn't,
I'm not that person.
I was never really naturally good at much.
So it wasn't like I was going to win the only way I could be people and things
was outworking them.
Yeah.
Other than that I,
it would be hard for me.
Yeah.
Usually that kind of person who like you,
well then the two kinds of people want who who is down to like screw someone
over or basically cheat cheating is what you're doing.
It's like I want to be here.
They don't necessarily want to quote unquote win because if you cheat it's not
really winning.
You know the whole benefit of winning is like overcoming certain things,
you know?
But when you cheat it's like you're not on any,
you cheated,
you know,
whatever.
So it's less about,
it's more about you understanding really what winning is and that's what you
like the winning,
you know?
Yes.
Why so?
Like people under my,
you know,
cheat and do this stuff.
It's like they don't want to win.
Case in point where,
I remember when when I was going to seal training,
there was people,
there was guys that would like brag about it.
They were going through the same seal training class and me,
same buds classes meet what they would like,
brag about it and like you could hear him talking to let's say some random
person.
Yeah,
we're on the seal training.
I wasn't bragging about that.
I'm just like,
hey man,
I'm a lucky I'm here.
And I realize that a lot of those people quit because they were comfortable.
They did just being able to say like seal training,
they were already good with it.
They were like,
Oh yeah,
I did what I'm supposed to do.
So me,
I want,
I don't want to do that.
I don't want to say anything until I made it through.
Yeah.
And so,
um,
yeah,
so,
so what I'm saying is similar to what you're saying,
they were satisfied just by being able to throw that out there,
that was enough for them.
So for someone that's willing to cheat and when are there,
either they're willing to step on someone.
Man,
it doesn't feel good to me.
That's never felt good to me.
Like if I got to step on someone,
I don't even want it.
I don't want that victory,
don't want it.
So it's like they want to,
some people want to look like they won and other people want to really win.
Yeah,
of course.
That's really the difference.
Yeah.
So back to the ego point,
when you start feeling like you're doing some of those negative things,
that's when you've got to put your ego in check.
That's what you got to support your coworker instead of sabotaging.
And that's when you got to pick the best plan out there instead of picking your
own.
That's when you say,
do you know what,
I'm happy with what I have in state of chasing things that I don't even need.
You know what I'm talking about when people like if you were,
there's been something that you wanted even though you actually didn't even
really want to put,
you just want it just cause you cause it's pure ego.
Your Ego.
Yeah.
Like when you're in the weight room,
well growing up like lifting weights,
some guys would do this where they'd be lifting weights and you can see a lot of
times in these like like a 24 hour fitness situation where you'd be live guys,
we'll be lifting weights.
And then one guy was,
he's like Dang,
he's lifting kind of a lot.
You'll see someone all of a sudden be doing that same exercise.
Like trying to live more than that.
He doesn't know him not lifting with him.
He wasn't even doing that exercise.
It wasn't even his workup,
but he'll like try to do it.
You know,
probably you weren't even doing that exercise.
You weren't doing bench today and now you're doing bench chasing something.
You don't even worry.
Don't even need it that day.
Don't need it that day.
Uh,
that's another big one is like when I talked about subordinates,
instead of cutting down your subordinates,
you start lifting them up,
you start making them shine,
you start giving them the credit,
making them shine even brighter than yourself.
That's,
that's the beautiful thing.
When you can put your ego in check and you can make that happen.
Making your own boss look good,
having an open mind to new ideas.
Those are the things.
That's how you put your ego in check.
Those are the,
those are the hallmarks of having your ego in check.
Now,
sometimes people don't know when they need to put their ego in check.
And I think there is one really easy indicator to know when you need to just at
least like do an assessment of your ego.
And that is when you come into conflict with another person cause cause a huge
percentage of conflicts that you have with other people.
Our Ego Ego.
And so when you feel that conflict,
whether it's about positioning,
whether it's about an idea,
whether it's about a plan,
whether it's about,
oh no matter what it's about,
but if I'm in conflict with you on something,
I immediately,
I'm going to say,
okay,
wait a second,
is this your ego talking or are you,
is is this business or is this ego?
Yeah.
And if you do that,
you will find yourself,
you know,
any form of frustration or anger that you have.
Just check your ego and there's a good chance that you're going to be able to
take that thing,
get ahold of it and aggressively put it in check.
It's hard.
Your ego is a tough bastard.
Your ego man,
that thing wants the spotlight.
It wants to shine.
It wants the glory and it's,
it's driven.
You know,
that's a lot of you high achievers out there.
That's what's driving you and that's not a bad thing.
So when it comes time to harness that bad boy,
it can be a challenge.
But it's very rewarding when you make it happen.
It's,
it's rewarding in a long term gratification.
It's not immediate gratification generally.
You know,
you're given,
you're given your subordinates to all the credit for some,
for some project that they did.
You know that you could actually know that you did the bulk of the work.
Would you give it away?
That's not gratifying.
Immediately.
Immediately as like,
yeah,
that's right.
Put the accolades on my head loss.
That's immediate gratification that you're looking for.
No.
You say,
Hey boss,
you know what?
Don't put the accolades on my head.
Look at my team,
let's crown them.
Cause they really did a great job.
You know,
I'm just here to help them.
There's no gratification that,
but when you get feed back a week later,
a month later,
six months later,
people want to come and work for your team.
Now your team gets picked for another project.
That's the longterm gratification that you get when you keep your ego in check.
Yeah.
Okay.
Keep
that ego and check people meal.